body is authorized to meet
electronically this is a committee
orientation meeting
please note there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the amended
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271
3600 or email hcs
leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
and i will introduce our researcher
pam smarling from the house committee
research office who is assisting us on
the committee
all votes if any will be that are taken
during this meeting
will be done by roll call vote and we'll
start with a roll call ascendant
attendance when each member states their
presence please
also state whether there is anyone in
the room with you during this meeting
which is required of the right to know
and representative scitec would you call
the role
yes i'm going to call the role according
to the
uh roster as printed in the calendar
so that is the order in which i will be
calling names
representative mcguire i'm here in epsom
in my office alone representative
roy i am here and i am home alone
the clerk is home alone representative
pearson
i am on the allen shepherd memorial
highway
hands-free of course and i'm going to be
a little bit on the mobile side today
representative yakubovic
here at home alone representative alex
i'm here it's uh possible my wife
may wander through and hear it although
she's tied up on an education
orientation
representative allegro here
and alone in my home office i think we
heard that representative bailey is not
here but
let's give him a try no
uh rep oh wait no and lonzaro is not
on zara it's not here either is that
correct
okay representative assanto
i'm here and i'm alone thank you
uh representative uh goalie
i'm at home and my wife is in another
room
okay not at the senior center
you're not at the senior center right
representative stewart
i am present at my home uh alone for
except for a very nosy cat and john it's
good to be able to hear you today
uh it's good to be heard and not
viewed or whatever they say
representative
judy is not here but i'll say his name
do i hear him no i'm here
he's here excellent
oh okay representative judy is here
yes i'm having trouble reading it so
here's the phone
on your your uh screen
okay uh let's see
representative uh schultz
she's not in yet i can see her picture
you can't hear her
all right semi-present
why don't you repeat it i think i missed
you
representative schmidt here at my home
office
i am in dover and i am alone
representative fellows
okay representative funknow
i am here i am home in rochester alone
at the moment representative grota
i'm in my home in rye alone
representative o'brien
i'm having technical uh issues with
representative
o'brien but i'll have him here soon okay
ma'am i'm on the phone with him and he
hasn't received anything he
said yet right that was because of my
technical problems
and the phone call from representative
judy at the same time so i'm
on it
do you have word on representative
schultz
she's here i don't know
she's here she's here waving but we
can't hear her
well right now she looks like she's um
unmuted okay chris
you you should be on the music
so at this point we're short uh
the um
bailey and lonzara and
the rest is a full house
that looks like we're representative
schultz
um and o'brien we are he is on the
doorstep
in some sense okay
that is the role yes you're very faint
though so speak up
okay
that's representative schultz yeah
okay a little marker down is three
quarters present
and representative lonzara is just
coming in through from the attendees
okay all right still we're we're short
then
holy uh bailey
and o'brien should hopefully be here
soon
hopefully we i sent him the attendee
link
because i couldn't get into the um
individual link
and so i'll we'll talk about
hopefully another time
i think i'm seeing representative
lonzaro now
yes yeah he's here
he's one of those lucky people who has
the same vowel
all the way through his name
one person excellent
excellent attendance i'm impressed all
right
so to repeat uh we will not be having
any committee meetings
next week by because they're
testing out the procedures on the
election law committee
so but i have just started to work on
scheduling
and we have four early bills that have
to be out before the others
that are on the pensions pension system
and therefore it makes sense that the
first
bills we will be hearing will be for the
pension system
uh so for homework
you can read these bills pam is
collecting data
from previous experience with these
the only one that is that is a totally
new
issue is is a technical correction that
representative schuett put in
the rest are all uh repeaters
so pam is collecting the data that we've
had in the past on these and that should
make the hearings go more smoothly
all right and so for
rest of the orientation pam who who's uh
speaking jill perlow from the attorney
general's office
would you like me to bring her over yes
please
and we'll uh we'll start on executive
orders
okay she is on her way
there she is
hi jill you should be able to there you
go
okay can you hear me absolutely
we can excellent sometimes the
headphones help sometimes they don't so
i'm never sure so thank you
uh thank you everyone and uh thank you
chair maguire and representatives i'm
happy to be here today and i understand
what i've been asked to present uh to
this committee is just an overview of
the emergency power statutes um
that have really come to the forefront
over this past
year and so with that i've got a little
bit of an overview that i'm
planning to walk through and then i'm
happy to answer any questions um
so just to first introduce myself i'm
jill perlow i'm a senior assistant
attorney general with the department of
justice
i'm also the chief of our client
counseling unit in the in the civil
bureau so i'm
familiar and work with many of the state
agencies
across the state in looking at um the
emergency power statutes there's really
three
primary sources
that come into play the first is in rsa4
and it's sections 45-47
the next one is rsa21p and it's the
sections 34-53 that's the homeland
security and emergency management
section and then in certain
circumstances not all emergencies
we might be looking also at rsa 141c
which is within public health and that
is communicable diseases
so those are the real primary sources of
emergency powers
but before i jump really into the nitty
gritty of some of the details of um
those statues and what those powers are
and how they get implemented
um i always like to start with why to
understand
maybe what all those different pieces
are and where
i look to and saying well why are there
these emergency powers is the purpose
that's been laid out in the statutes by
the legislature
and the best description of that
please let me interrupt
for a second pam
[Music]
yes i don't see a recording on my
screen i'm sorry
that's
sure yes and actually uh miss perlow
if you have a presentation or some notes
that you could send us it would be very
much appreciated either
now or after the
okay i do i do have some notes that i've
pieced together i've put them a little
bit into
a slideshow i'm happy to
i sometimes unsuccessfully share my
screen so i'm happy to share my screen
i'm happy to just send them after the
fact i'm really just kind of walking
through
all of the the provisions so whatever
you would prefer
um how about both share your screen and
then send
us the uh the file when when we're done
sure i will do my best i know pam
we were talked about whether i'd be able
to share my screen and
let's see
you should have the the ability to share
your screen
like magic does it look like an
actual slideshow though that's always
well you can see the whole
um right but let me see if i can
reset okay that's excellent
all right figuring out i have too many
screens and which
one it has to be on to make sure it
shares properly it's always
the excitement so okay so this is where
i'll
i will start back over um with just
this is the outline of the three primary
sources of
emergency powers we're looking at rsa4
colon 45-47
that's the government the governor's
powers statute 21p
34-53 is our homeland security and
emergency management powers
and then 141c is looking at like public
health and communicable diseases
i feel like i hear somebody speaking so
everyone please mute themselves
i just didn't know if someone had a
question so
where i was then moving to is the why
are there emergency powers and looking
at the purpose
which is in rsa 21p 34 lays it out and
to make sure that the state is
adequately prepared to preserve the
lives and the property of the people of
the state when faced with
natural and human-caused disasters by
providing emergency management powers
too
and it's broken down into the governor
other executive heads of governing
bodies of the state such as local
officials
having local organizations for emergency
management to make sure that
those emergency powers are coordinated
across the state
with other states and the federal
government um with that coordination
being to the maximum extent possible so
that
purpose is found in 21p 34 and
sets the stage for kind of everything
that flows from it
that's the why are we here and so what
are the types of disasters that's also
found in this purpose
paragraph of the statute and so it's
fires
floods hurricanes earthquakes uh a
prolonged
power outage um disruption or
contamination of the food or water
supply
degradation of critical facilities and
vital systems disruption of
communication systems
or other natural technological or human
causes including acts of terrorism so
there's a lot of
different types of disasters that might
implicate a state of emergency and and
looking at these emergency powers so
this is the types of issues that the
powers
were designed to think about respond to
to preserve the lives and property of
the state so that's that's the why
and to kind of move on to the who what
where
when of of these emergency powers the
first is who
who can declare a state of emergency and
there's
two bodies that can either the governor
or the legislature
and that is found in rsa4 colon 45
paragraph one we'll get into the
mechanics of that a little bit further
but there's
two different individual ore bodies
that can do that but what is a state of
emergency i mean we just rattled off a
bunch of or i just rattled off a bunch
of
different disasters that could occur
fires floods but they're not
not each one would necessarily result in
a state of emergency and it needs to be
a condition
situation or set of circumstances so one
of those types of events
but it needs to be so extremely
hazardous or dangerous to life or
property
that and then i highlighted
extraordinary measures some type of
extraordinary measures need to be taken
and we find that definition in rsa 21p
and to connect the dots a little bit
we've got rsa4 colon 45 tells us
that the governor or the legislature can
declare a state of emergency as defined
in
21p 35. so
we've got some type of incident has
happened
it's not just your typical unfortunately
we have typical floods we have floods we
have fires we have snow storms we have
all sorts of different events can happen
but it's got to be
so hazardous that we need to take some
type of extraordinary action
so we know who can act we know under
what circumstances
someone can act what about where where
does this event have to be occurring and
so we need to think about
where is this conditioned situation set
of circumstances occurring it's got to
be within the state
it's rsa4 colon 45 tells us that
and it could be either focused in a
particular area
or if it's beyond local control it could
impact the whole state and the statutes
recognize this
could be narrow or broad
and it really depends we've had snow
storms that only impact
um up north we could have an ice storm
that's really
bad in the western part of the state you
could have a hurricane type event
weather event that's only on the
seacoast
so you can see where there could be a
need to respond
on a just more local basis but it could
also impact the whole state you could
have a storm that impacts the whole
state
so we've got who we've got what we've
got where
also when is a consideration and
it needs to be this type of disaster of
major proportions but we don't have to
wait
it could be either that it's imminent or
it could be that it's already occurred
so it could be that we see the storm
coming we're monitoring the storm we
think it's going to be bad enough that
perhaps
it requires a proactive declaring of a
state of emergency in an area
or perhaps we don't know that it's
coming it could be a fire that
occurred and really would devastate a
particular area
it could be something that sudden
happened maybe a storm that was worse
than anyone anticipated
and so we're responding after the fact
so it's either imminent we can see it
coming we take proactive actions
or it's already occurred and so then we
can respond as
and well we get to the how so we've kind
of got all of the pieces together
we you know we've got either we've got
an event that's happened
that we feel needs uh extraordinary
measures to be taken
um it's happening in a particular area
it's either imminent
or it's about to happen and so there
needs to be a response so how do we get
there how do we start implementing these
emergency powers
and it's that the governor or the
legislature and the governor will do it
by issuing an executive order
or the legislature by concurrent
resolution declares the state of
emergency
and there's some specific requirements
and it's going through all of those
steps we just did
what is the nature of the emergency is
it a storm is it
a disease a communicable disease that
we're dealing with
is it a um flooding type situation is
there a man-made action that's happened
um where is that happening
what is making this an emergency what's
brought it about what makes it such a
threat to
life and safety and what is it that
we're facing with and then how long
do we anticipate this emergency to to
exist
with a cap in place it's limited to 21
days
and so you could envision a situation
where there's a storm you think it's
only going to be one or two days maybe
three
it gets declared for those couple of
days at the end of those couple of days
you need to assess does this
have things returned to normal are we
able to lift the emergency do we need to
extend it
um if you're unsure on the time it could
be up to the 21 days
and then at the end of 21 days it's a
requirement that
you know the governor or the legislature
reassess the situation are we still
facing all of those same factors and
then it can be renewed
if it doesn't get renewed it just ends
after the end of 21 days so
that is yep sorry to interrupt but the
raise hand button is not visible on my
screen for some reason
for how many years can the governor uh
continue to renew
there is nothing in statute that would
cap that it is a requirement that every
21 days
that an assessment of the situation
um be considered whether it needs to be
renewed again
um the how does a state of emergency end
is really the next three
bullets on the slides here one it just
doesn't get renewed it's
allowed to expire at the end of the 21
days or at the end of whatever period of
time
an emergency was declared if maybe
you're in the middle of a
21 day cycle or maybe you're in the
middle of you've declared it's been
declared for
a week or two weeks and you assess the
situation and say
wait this there's no longer this
imminent threat there's no longer a need
for these emergency
um actions then the governor is required
to issue an executive order ending
the state of emergency and then the
third piece is that the legislature by
concurrent resolution
may also terminate a state of emergency
that the governor has declared
so those are the three ways in statute
that an emergency can end
so so long as those conditions still
exist
and the governor was to find that those
conditions
still exist a renewal could continue to
be issued
and so once a state of emergency has
been declared that then triggers
a series of emerging emergency powers
keeping in mind that
the whole i concept back to that why
what is the purpose of this
is in order to protect the life
and property of the state extraordinary
measures need to be taken so this is the
set of extraordinary measures that are
then
made available upon the declaration of a
state of emergency
and there's a couple sources of these
powers as well four colon 45
provides a list of them it includes
assuming control of emergency management
forces and helpers in the state
obtaining and transferring materials or
services for emergency management
purposes
evacuating part of the population
as i read through these i think of the
different types of emergencies you could
face and you could have a weather event
that might require an evacuation of an
area you could have a fire event that
could require an evacuation removal from
office of any public officer who's
engaged in emergencies
other functions powers and duties as are
necessary to promote and secure the
safety and protection
of the population and to declare an
emergency temporary location of
government
so those are some of the powers in four
colon 45.
additional powers are found in 4 46
47 and then 21p and those include
acquiring or disposing of real or
personal property entering mutual aid
agreements with other states
having emergency lines of succession for
appointed officials in state government
making amending suspending orders rules
and regulations necessary
to respond to the emergency accepting
services equipment supplies and funds
from the federal government
and then also local governor and local
political subdivisions can accept
services supplies materials from private
individuals and companies
and so those are some additional
emergency powers that are provided
again keeping in mind the purpose was to
provide the governor and other executive
officials within local political
subdivisions
certain powers you can see this comes
through
in some of these different emergency
power provisions
and then specific in the public health
arena
so these may not be triggered and would
likely not be triggered in those
scenarios of the
snow storm and the fire but when we have
a communicable disease for example
we look to the hhs commissioner and
perhaps
in conjunction with the governor the
governor has the powers
also outlined in 141c as well as in 21p
really specific to responding to public
health concerns and those
include ordering individuals to seek
treatment and care as necessary to
reduce a public threat
um health threat to order isolation and
quarantine
of people to quarantine items
commodities conveyances
baggage cargo that poses a particular
threat
um control the safe disposal of corpses
purchase distribute and ration
pharmaceutical agents provide laboratory
services
order evacuation and de contamination of
buildings
canceling of public gatherings and
operating temporary acute care centers
and so that is a very high level
overview just to try and walk us through
and i think i can
stop sharing my screen
of as i laid out the kind of who uh
where when why's and hows of the
emergency powers um
including how these get uh
triggered through the governor's actions
or through the legislature's act and
actions when those types of um what
types of incidents could
result in them being triggered and then
what are the powers that come with
the triggering of those emergency powers
so with that that's my overview i don't
know
if there's questions or how to best uh
turn that back over to you for any
follow-up
okay there will undoubtedly be questions
um if people would raise their hand
i'll call them representative schuett
thank you madam chair um i noticed
miss perlow that excuse me
sorry the
emergency powers could be removed by
action of the legislature or the
uh data of emergency i guess i should
say
and i was wondering if the legislature
took that step
would that nullify the governor's
ability to accept
federal funds beyond that date
so once um if the legislature was to
take
that step you know as we talked about
that
once the um powers
are once the state of emergency is
declared then
a number of powers are exercised
i would have to kind of take a deeper
dive on that specific question
on you know how it is 21p 43 because
that's the specific
acceptance of federal funds um relate to
the existence of a state of emergency
um and then also another question would
need to be
in the event that the legislature was to
undo the state of emergency
are there limits on the governor's
ability to
then declare an additional state of
emergency if the conditions were so
available so that's a
interesting question in terms of how
those two connect um
so i think it's a good it's a good
question the concept
would be that you know it's only those
powers
um are implicated with the existence of
the state of emergency and uh we'd have
to take a close look at how that
specific statute relates
thank you uh ms perlow if you could do
that
looking we would very much like to to
see that
and representative lucas uh hello thank
you madam chair and actually related to
that previous question i think you'd
also have to look into
the federal rules on the disbursement of
the money as well
but my i have two questions hopefully
brief one is
um what if anything is in the
constitution the new hampshire
constitution
related to declaring the state of
emergency and the governor's powers
now i'm going off the top of my head
which is always dangerous i don't think
there's anything specific that says oh
there's an emergency um
power authority however you know the
constitution's written in a broader
brush of
the governor as the supreme executive of
the state and then and has some broader
concepts along those lines um as well
okay so you could please look into it
and and just uh double check and see if
there's any anything at all in there
around that
and uh excuse me representative i'd like
to
while she's looking into that there is a
statement that the power to suspend the
execution of the laws is reserved to the
legislature
and that i think needs to be looked at
in consideration of the
executive powers please continue yeah
thank you follow up um another question
and and that is i mean in the statutes
just listed
it said the governor could if i remember
correctly you know suspend or modify
regulations and
there was something else in there but i
don't believe it said statute so
you know does the governor have any
power to modify
any existing statutes that have been
passed by the legislature
so in terms of so the
and i'm happy to provide uh some
additional information on each of these
i'm familiar with the
provision in the constitution about the
legislature's ability to
suspend statutes
in passing the various emergency powers
that have been outlined here it has you
know as
it has given the governor some very
broad authority
um including the one uh representative
that you
are citing which is in four colon 45
nope not that one um my other one four
colon 47
3 which is make suspend make amends to
spend and rescind
necessary orders rules and regulations
necessary to respond
to the emergency and also
a broad authority to take such other um
have such other functions powers and
duties as are necessary
and so the legislature
in passing these laws has
provided the governor the authority to
take these additional actions
um and so those are the places that
the governor has looked to in taking
this authority to suspend statutes
uh follow-up but i can in in following
up i can piece together those so that
i'm not just doing it on the fly right
here for you um
but those are the the pieces that were
connected for that
okay uh thank you for that and just one
final thing and that is
um on that section that you know
goes on about all other uh actions is
there any limiting principle i mean
basically
if there's a declared state of emergency
is there anything the governor cannot do
if he believes it's necessary related to
the state of emergency
i mean i think that is always a fair
question it does need to be
you know to promote and secure the
safety and protection of the civilian
population
and um there are limiting principles in
there
and ensuring that that is uh the purpose
of the actions that are being taken and
so that's the
the limitations that are on it all right
thank you
are there any other questions
all right that's a that's amazing um
thank you very much and ms furlow and we
will uh
be delighted to receive your your slides
and the
investigations that that you're going to
provide us
sure
all right thank you i will be sure pam i
can follow up with you and provide you
the slides and i've got the
three pieces three questions that i
think i took down and if there's
anything further i'm happy to follow
back up as well
i'm i'm sure we'll be seeing you when we
hear the bills we've got on this issue
but uh
good to be prepared sounds good thank
you
thank you
[Applause]
oh if no one objects
i think we will go to the basic
introduction to rule making that we had
planned for this afternoon because i
just as rather we finished this morning
rather than having to come back um
if i could ask a question uh i'd love to
to do that my only question is given
that the time of that meeting was
noticed in the calendar
please leave a message after the tone um
you know is that a problem well i don't
know
uh was it wasn't the whole or a
committee orientation
noticed for 10 o'clock oh i'm sorry
you're right i was just thinking that
your notice to us had it broken up but
it wasn't in the calendar thank you
for correcting me
so this is a very high level
introduction to rulemaking
if you want to get the details
the director of the administrative rules
office
scott eaton is preparing a
multi-part introduction to rule making
for the new members of gelcar
so you're more than welcome to it to uh
participate in that but for the
committee
members we we really need to have
the top level position on rulemaking
so an administrative rule is written by
an agency and it defines
their dealing with the public it does
and sometimes
other portions of government it does not
uh it deals with the regu the community
that's regulated or interested in what
they're doing
administrative rules are valid for 10
years
and they cannot be enforced after they
expire
that was an accomplishment of just a
couple of years ago
because a number of agencies were just
letting their rules expire
and kept on enforcing them regardless
but we've
we have actually clamped down on that
rules have the force and effect of law
and that means that writing rules is a
legislative activity
and in new hampshire at least the
legislature
continues to get involved we don't just
tell the agency to
make rules and then let them go at it we
review and approve all the rules that
are in effect
the review is done primarily by the
staff
of the legislative uh sir
administrative rules office and
the and then they are reviewed by the
joint legislative committee on
administrative rules
or jail car i'm the vice chair this year
and representative schmidt shut and
fonteno i believe are members of the
committee
our alternate and representative roy
penn scitec has been but isn't this year
so as a member of edna you're
high on the list of people to be tagged
to go to jail card
basically these the staff will review
all rules
in excruciating detail and they work
with the agencies to make sure
that they comply with the statutory
authority
that they have the proper style and
formatting
and they have and that the what the
fiscal impact
is defined the rules go through
the uh the legislative budget assistant
the same way bills do
so we look at the fiscal impact of the
rules
before we approve them um
jail car has five house members five
senators plus alternates and generally
the house alternates get a good workout
because the senators don't attend very
well
it meets every every month year round
jail car at holds public meetings and
it can approve a rule it can request
changes fixes and so forth generally
the agency will comply with a request
and come back with a revised
rule and then then we can do that
jail card does not have full authority
to object to rules
uh not meeting legislative intent
exceeding their authority
excessive fiscal impact and not in the
public interest
which is rather not as effective as we
as some people might like in particular
jail car cannot object to a rule
because they don't like the principle if
the
legislature has in its glorious wisdom
passed a stupid law
then the agency has full authority to
write stupid rules to implement it
and sometimes we get a lot of attention
for something like that but jail car
cannot change a rule
that complies with the bad law we can
simply say
we'll have to fix the law okay
if there is a an objection jail car can
make a final objection which
can go either two ways if that's all
they do
then the rule does not have the
presumption
that it meets legislative intent so if
it's challenged in court
it's a lot more difficult to defend
but if to really block it delcar can
put in a resolution to block the rule
which would have to which is can be
introduced basically at any time
it has to be approved by the house and
the senate and it blocks the rule
completely
and this happens about once a year that
a final
objection is filed sometimes the agency
will change their rule
if they're sometimes the house and
senate
will pass the resolution and block it in
which case the agency
needs to change their rule because it is
not
in effect and
sometimes it the changes get worked out
in the process
we had one about the medical board
my first term where it passed the ha the
resolution passed the house
and then by the time it got to the
senate they worked out a deal with the
agency and changed the rule enough
that the resolution was not necessary
okay that's uh
oh rsa 541a
defines the whole rulemaking process we
are the keepers of 541a so any changes
to it will be coming to us
and we've got a few uh we
also are responsible to make sure that
no
rule is passed by any committee or
by the house that has what's called
broad making broad rulemaking authority
this is where the law says
you know the agency will make rules to
implement the purpose of this chapter
we've tried to get rid of that in some
cases we were successful
in other cases it's still there it's
always a temptation for the legislature
to leave the details to somebody else
[Music]
for example last last session i think it
was
the pfest rules the legislature did not
set
set a limit did not even say what the
the criteria were for setting element
just said
des figure out of read the number and
put it in rules and it'll be effective
okay and that's that's the high level
detail representative schmidt is going
to give you a few more um
points because he's been on jail car
longer than i have
carol can i ask a question certainly
so on the final objection where it has
to pass the house and the senate
is that a simple majority vote or is
that a
super majority vote and also who can
file such an objection does it have to
be a member of jail car
or can it be any member of either body
a final objection is filed generally by
the chair of jail car
and because it's not during the normal
bill cycle
so you'd have to go to rules but
the rules committee essentially says to
jail car if you have a final objection
will bring it in any time and it is a
simple majority vote and it does not
have to be signed by the governor
thank you
thank you uh madam chair um so
generally speaking um i very much agree
with
the chair's presentation regarding
the rules
for the new members of the committee
of course we are called the name of our
committee is executive departments and
administration
which kind of makes us a little bit of a
mystery committee for
most of the representatives because
unlike most of the committee names where
the name
pretty well says what the committee does
or what his area of jurisdiction is
um executive departments and
administration
it certainly says something about what
we do but uh but most
i remember before i was assigned to jail
to
edna i i had really no idea what
what what the committee actually did
but our job is to oversee legislation
and to vet legislation which deals with
um the executive departments because we
all know that we have
you know three branches of government uh
the legislatures you know set
and adopts the statutes
and the executive branch is
responsible for implementing those
uh those statutes and in the course of
doing so it
it grants a certain aspect of its of its
power
to the executive department
to write rules to implement them but
the legislature jealously guards
its power to legislate and that's what
the
administrative rules unit is for
is to vet the rules which
the agency is is writing to implement
the statute to make sure that
that the rules do not and the two
primary pillars of the
of the administrative rules uh
oversight process are whether something
exceeds legislative authority and the
other is it it cannot be contrary to
legislative intent
those are the two main aspects that we
that our attorneys are we have three
full-time attorneys
a very experienced as the director has
been with the
it was administrative rules unit for
over 30 years
um and one of the attorneys has been
there for over 20 years
um and so they're as as carol said
they are extremely meticulous i mean
they'll draw little lines and say you
know
the comma goes down there or this needs
to be a new paragraph
so they look at absolutely everything
but the most important aspect is
is they make sure that the the rule does
not lead
exceed legislative authority nor be
contrary to legislative intent
and carol already talked about the fact
that
there are three that the jail car cannot
present
the administrative sorry rules from
um from being put in place by the
uh by the agency um
but uh if if we enter a fight
the normal process is if there's some
process
problem with a rule and i have to be a
little bit more specific here because
uh if we have a
a 15-page rule to implement a certain
uh authority um
is that is we call that a rule but every
little provision
of the of the rule is also referred to
as a rule
and ordinarily if there's a problem it's
not going to be the whole rule
it's going to be some little provision
that
um you know that is at fault or
defective or whatever
and i'll give you an example of
that type of thing there was a statute
passed about
15 years ago to to ban smoking in
restaurants and bars
and in the course of the rule to
implement that statute
there was a an administrative fine
that was put in there in order to
provide the so-called hammer if you will
because if there were no fine
then the proprietor might say well i
don't like this
statute and i'm not going to implement
it and there's no penalty
so that so i can disregard the law and
there's no way that you that the
government can sanction me or my
establishment for
violating that statute um and so
we all recognize that and but the but
the the statute did not actually include
any authority to implement a fine
but the rule did and so uh
because we all recognize without a
penalty that people were going to
disregard the statute
more readily than if there were some
kind of cost
and the the i think the the fine that
the uh
that the that hhs put in there was about
either 50 or so or maybe a hundred
dollars for the first
violation um but there was no authority
for it and the
the agency recognized that we all
recognized it so that was an instance
where we
filed a so-called joint resolution carol
already talked about that a little bit
and
so the the joint resolution did not stop
the whole rule
it only stopped the provision that
imposed that administrative fine
um and then it's like any other bill it
has to pass both chambers uh and if if
it does pass both chambers
then that particular aspect is is
prohibited
um and the agency recognized all that
they came in and asked the
legislature to support
the joint resolution but also to give
them the authority to
impose such a fine and that was the
outcome
but carol said it happens about once a
year and i would say
in my 14 years of experience on gel car
that the joint resolutions are pretty
rare
uh because because the
the attorneys are going to see that
right off the bat
and they're going to say this can't pass
the jail car
you'll you'll get a joint resolution um
and so the agency wants to have the rule
approved
because it has much more viability
in front of the courts if if the jail
car has
has approved it and that's one of the
reasons why
uh the final objection pass
part of the of the statute of of our
541a
uh does uh you know does not get adopted
too often
because um that also takes away
the state's backing of the the agency
and makes it more tempting for
stakeholders
uh to you know to take it to take the
agency to court
so peter can i ask a question of course
please do
um so a lot of the rules uh
as you mentioned are um to raise
uh fines and fees that were not put in
statute can you tell us what
the where those fines and fees go are
they if they're not designated in
statute do they automatically go to the
general fund or does the agency retain
them
well that's an excellent question and
it's one that's
quite often not understood by
the by the legislature in general
uh the even the new members of our
committee now know more about
administrative rules and than about 90
of our colleagues because they don't
have any
involvement with it as we as as we are
explaining
it to you here um so uh as a
as a general rule uh first of all the
the agency cannot just uh just decide to
implement a fine or a fee uh with no
legislative authority that that just
can't happen
um because it it's not legal
uh and the attorneys would that that
would be
immediately come to the attention as it
did in the example i just gave about the
smoking ban so
uh so fees and fines are ordinarily
uh either the either the statute will
give the
agency the authority to set fees um
or it will retain that right for itself
and then it puts
the the the fee or the fine in the
statute
um but uh and it it and the the revenue
that's raised
by the fees and the fines is
essentially intended to to fund the cost
of
the regulatory process for that
particular
uh for that particular profession
so and most of the
most the licensed professions in the
state of new hampshire
are overseen by a board so there's a
plumbing board the electrician's board
and so forth
and most of these boards are what's
called 120
125 boards which means that they have to
raise 125 percent of the cost
of their operations so that
it doesn't fall on the taxpayers it
falls on the people who
either want to have a hunting license or
a plumber's license or an electrician's
license
um and and the people pay for that
by in the cost of uh of their plumbing
operation
which goes to their plumber which as a
plumber has to have a license
and so forth it goes up the chain and
the 125 percent concept is in order to
make sure that that they don't have to
operate to the penny
because as you can imagine there's a
certain amount of ebb
representative schmidt you're going off
track the
fines aren't fines not
sanctioned by statute are not the usual
reason for objecting to a rule
it happened no no i didn't i didn't say
that no i didn't say that
but you're answering the question as if
it were
the most usual case is that it exceeds
the legislative authority
and there's it and sometimes there's a
disagreement about what the legislation
intends right my question really though
is what happens you
let's say we write a law that says to to
representative schmidt's point
no smoking and the agency can
set whatever fines and then gelcar
approves a fine of fifty dollars
does that fine automatically go back to
the agency or does the statute have to
say where the money goes
well um
by and large as i said the revenues that
are raised
are for the purpose of um enforcing the
law of course but also
uh in order to fund the cost of um
of the operations of the agency um
and as as i say the as i was saying
when carol interrupted uh to make her
point uh
and the the the the costs of the agency
are a steady a relatively steady cost
right they have
staff they have expenses and so forth
and so on
and the 125 fee
of uh the license fee for example uh
is intended to fund the cost of of the
staff
and the oversight and the regulation and
so forth
and 25 percent is is to give
some uh some some play
some some slop if you will because
sometimes the costs are
are exceeded in a particular year um and
by the uh by the revenues
and that and that extra money flows over
into the general fund to get to the
point you're raising terry
um but we this is one of the problems
that was raised yesterday
by the director that some of the
agencies
are you know well above the 125 percent
fund
uh funding and that that is not the
purpose
uh for making the agencies a cash cow
for the legislature
in my opinion and i think it's a
generally agreed to opinion
but the the the as i say there's some
good years and some linear
lean years for the agency the 25 is
supposed to cover that
so that they don't have to come back to
the legislature
they just you know they have a little
bit of of
leeway and they and they use that in a
in a lean year
and in a good year that
excess revenue is supposed to flow over
into the general fund
um and that that's one of the things
that this
is our committee has been very
conscientious about trying to
to fine-tune it so that we don't have
agencies
right right biggest problem i think
thank you representatives
you know we've certainly given him soft
food but he doesn't really like canned
food so we use um
moist thank you um i
i'm hearing pam is anybody hearing me
at any time yes we hear you when we hear
pam too
but he seems good pam will have to mute
herself
so um i attended a jail car hearing last
year
or well maybe it was in um 2019
and i noticed there were a lot of items
on a consent
calendar so my question was
how do things get on that consent
calendar
versus having a hearing okay
i can answer that simple enough yes go
on representative schmidt
okay so so just like with legislation
if if the the attorneys look at a rule
and and it's there's no problem with it
whatsoever
then they put it on the consent calendar
now any member of gel car can pull
any item off the consent calendar but
we have a lot of work every month and
sometimes we have to have a second
meeting if that's if if our workload
requires it
and so we don't ordinarily pull off
rules that the attorneys have already
vetted and have found completely
compliant with
uh are the four pillars that carol
already explained and i
added some additional information too um
and then
the consent calendar gets adopted with
one single
motion and one single vote by the jail
car when it comes up
but the attorneys
when a rule comes in the attorneys will
look at look at it and they they'll they
might say of a certain provision
they talk with the agency and they say
this is this is going to cause
problems for the jail car you're not
going to get approval of this
and because the agency wants approval
they will rewrite the rule
uh to to comply with the
attorney's requests but there usually
comes a time
that the agency believes it has the
authority to do it this way
and it won't budge with regard to
uh that particular aspect and the
attorneys say
well we can't sign off on this
particular aspect only the gel car can
do that
and those are the rules that go on the
regular calendar not on the consent
count if you go on the regular calendar
for a jalakar meeting and i strongly
recommend to
members of this committee because jail
car will be
referenced frequently almost constantly
with regard
to our the bills that we are dealing
with
and it's good to you know tune in and
find out how the jail car works
if you do you'll be one of the rare
legislators whoever appeared before
jail car and so
then it happens the attorney when the
bill is when the rule is heard before
the jail car
the the attorney will say um
now look on page five rule
paragraph such and such and so and so um
and either it's a little too vague or
it's too rubber baggy uh
too too much leeway uh and
and the then the the
public will frequently object to this
that or what have you
um and the agents who will explain why
they've done it this way
and sometimes they say this is the only
way that we can do this
and we believe we have the authority to
do it and
they can adopt a rule over our final
objection only a joint resolution can
stop
a particular paragraph from being
implemented while the legislature contin
considers that joint resolution but
so that that's basically it and then and
so frequently they
the attorneys will say well it's up to
you
whether you want to prove this uh and
and this is the the attorneys have the
same objection to this rule 10 years ago
when it was first implemented and the
jail car approved it
but they bring it back to us because
again they can't sign off on some things
only the only the gel car can do it
schuett
thank you man um i wanted to point out i
believe
that i've heard that new hampshire
is the own or certainly one of very few
states that does take a legislative
oversight of rules that are implemented
uh by virtue of the laws that have been
passed is that
your understanding yes we are one of the
very few
i don't know of any other that does it
specifically
in particular congress does not have any
oversight over the rulemaking process
representative lekkis thank you madam
chair
um you had made a comment about uh
um providing you know some kind of
oversight
over uh preventing bills with uh broad
room
rulemaking authority how does that work
uh we most bills that have
explicit rulemaking authority come to
edna as a second committee
so we will we will re see them there
uh otherwise we
re the invite the share and the vice
chair take a look at bills and other
committees that do not come to us
and have in some cases flag bills as
being incorrect by having broad rule
making authority
we've been able to get some sent to edna
others have been tabled or amended to
get rid of the
broad rulemaking authority others
sometimes have been railroaded through
okay thank you right
we when carol came into the legislature
that was one of the things that she
noticed uh right off the bat
that that very often the older rules
would say
that com you know the agency shall write
uh rules to implement the statute
and it it'll say right in the bill
you'll see it
uh according to or to um 544
rsa 541a that is an open flag that it's
an administrative rules situation but
not every bill has that
um and uh so
um if if
that's the case uh then that will always
come to us
sometimes it doesn't have it that
reference
um and so um
that what what we got rid of a lot of
stuff that that
where that broad rule making authority
was granted but in many cases the whole
structure
of the agency was built on this
on the statutory authority to write
rules to implement the statute
and if we'd if we'd remove that
provision there would have been no basis
for the whole
agency structure to handle that whole
area
and the whole the thing would have
collapsed so we couldn't um
remove the authority there because it
had been in effect for years
and everything was dependent on it but
we don't let them do that anymore
because
because it it's way too loose the agency
doesn't really like to do that they
would much rather have the authority of
the
of the legislature to do x y or z that's
why
now fees and fines are ordinarily
included in statutes right
and in fact one of the projects we did
in uh 11 was to repeal
a good number of broad rulemaking
authority
and replace it with specific rulemaking
authority where needed uh
one one key point was that the entire
medicaid
program was being run under the
commissioner of dhs hss's
broad rulemaking authority to implement
the purposes of the
of the chapter and so now
that was changed and we now specifies
they can come up with
cri the requirements to be on medicaid
how they determine payments and things
like
that so it is much much more tightly
defined and restricted
right if i could just say one thing that
that you
mentioned earlier that is um that when i
came on the gel car
14 15 years ago um that we had
lots of rules that had expired lots of
rules
some of them had been expired for years
um
and the agency was continuing to run
their shop
based on these expired rules uh although
there actually was
a court decision uh that
that had already happened at the time i
came on
that said uh you know that expired rules
were not rules
they had no authority the agency could
not implement that
and so there was a big push to to clean
up all those expired rules most of them
had been
worked on by the time carroll came onto
the jail car several years later
and now we rarely have rules that uh
that have expired more than
you know a couple of weeks or a month or
so because they
they're working on them they just
haven't got them done because it is
very very time consuming to write rules
and and the
the bigger agencies like hhs or des
or safety they have a rules writing unit
they have a rules writing coordinator
and they have
specialist attorneys who you know who
and
agency members who are very
knowledgeable who are constantly working
on rules
but the smaller agencies the little
departments very often don't have a
rules unit
and so they were the ones who were most
remiss as the general rule
now we rarely find or not frequently
anyway
expired rules um
but um so a lot of things have been
tightened up because
when carol came on uh and became the
chair
uh that was one of the things that she
was especially you know dedicated to
cleaning up the rules and we've
gotten much tighter in the meantime
all right thank you representative
schmidt are there any other questions or
comments
okay any other questions or comments
about the committee
well in that case i would suggest we
adjourn
we will not be having any full committee
meetings next week
uh pam do you ever have something to add
no i was just coming on to see if there
was anything
i i you know you might ask or or say i i
did send an email to
to everybody a few minutes ago with the
the full list of the nine bills that you
identified at the outset
of the meeting and um that will uh
that will let us get a head up yes
representative grota
thank you madam chair will it be
possible at one time
um to get a list of all the bills that
we're gonna hear
yes you've go you go to the advanced
bill search and go in by committee
okay there were 49 the last i checked
right okay
thank you representative schultz
can you hear me now yes oh good okay
um i really hope this doesn't come
across as partisan because i mean this
is a very nonpartisan point
i very much appreciate that we have had
these meetings over zoom
and want to point out to or kindly
suggest to anyone who
has had trouble with zoom to seek
help from those of us who can help
troubleshoot or lend equipment
or like i have an extra wi-fi rider uh
router that i'd be willing to give to
representative scitec if that would help
his technological issues
and i i think um i may be hyper aware of
these issues because of my own
susceptibility to um
illness with milder flus
so i really appreciate that we've had
these in zoom
over zoom and i just am trying to make
the point that hopefully we can over the
next week work out any of our
technological issues
so we can continue to have this as our
platform
thank you that's uh that's very kind of
you
and the decision is above my pay grade
these the speaker and committee services
are working on
figuring out whether or not we will have
remote or hybrid meetings
um i think at the moment they're leaning
toward remote
we will find out you'll know us shortly
after i do
representative lekis i just wanted to
know
um are all of the lsr's bills and i'll
have all the bills that will be assigned
to edna
assigned and if not do we know when that
will happen
as far as i know they are not yet all
assigned
and it will be soon that's the answer i
can get
sorry about that but i understand thank
you but uh
looking at you know with four early
bills on pensions
and another five that are related i
figured that's enough to get people
started on it if i may add madam chair
the according to the rules
the last day to introduce bills
is january 15th so the clerk
will try to have all of those lsrs
in the house's possession introduced by
that
right so that's tomorrow that's soon
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair so um just for
every
attication for those of you who are a
little bit of glutton for punishment
um there will be a jail car meeting
tomorrow uh starting at nine o'clock
and we have an interesting bill uh or
not built
an interesting rule uh regarding uh
and provision of services by specialty
hospitals where there'll be public
testimony and so forth so
that might be something that if
anybody's interested
talk to me offline and uh and i can give
you a hint on how to get
get on the the bill at the rule hearing
tomorrow
thank you for the yeah everyone is
welcome to to jail car it's a public
meeting
and it's always exciting and lots of fun
for everyone
and the link to that's right
observe the meeting is this calendar
right it's it's it is public it's
available
all right well thank you everyone for
coming uh
i hope that we will manage to
figure out what we can do of this year
and how we can do our business
and the people's business as efficiently
as possible
have a good weekend and uh thank you
thank you bye see some of you tomorrow
terry
thank you not if i see you first